what happened at the after the game was
uh was
unfortunate there was there's a
misunderstanding about the game
ball
um you it was Oscar she's first NBA
official NBA point so we always get the
game ball we were not thinking about
giannis's franchise
record so we grabbed the ball
and um a couple couple cou minutes later
several of their players ended up in our
hallway and there was a
big a big
uh I don't know I don't know what to
call it a fracus Mele melee whatever I
don't think any punches were landed but
my general manager got elbowed in the
ribs by one of their players um and so
he certainly has a bruis bruised rib and
who knows you know if it's anything more
than that but um unfortunate situation
we don't need the the official game ball
there's two game balls there um you know
we could have taken the other one um but
it didn't need to escalate to that and
so you
know really
just you know
unfortunate third game we played these
guys within two and a half three weeks
so things are heated with the
competition and uh you know I I
understand all that but for it to come
into the hallway was didn't need it
didn't need to happen that
way just to get a little bit more detail
there I'm sorry what um I guess how did
it escalate I mean I think I'm not sure
you know I'm I'm just explaining what
happened I mean there's people tweeting
things out there I'm telling you exactly
what happened I'm I'm not naming names
but I think it's pretty clear you know
um who was involved and and look it's
just you know I think end up being a
three-hour game you know with with all
the things going on and ailon free
throws and all that and you know just
just too much you know so just to
clarify you said that your guys PM was
El
player don't know who don't know who I
don't know who I'm not naming any names
I'm just tell you what
happened there were four or there were
four or five of their guys in our
hallway you know so
anyway just stuff that doesn't need to
happen you know the thing with the ball
is just I mean we don't care that much
about the official game ball and you
know all that kind of stuff I mean but
um anyway unfortunately that'll be a
bigger story